down the ages past Allah sent his
Messengers to deliver humankind from
Darkness to light invite all to the way
of thy Lord with wisdom and beautiful
preachings and argue with them in the
ways that are best and most
gracious that's also the ongoing mission
of Islamic Research Foundation or irf
spreading the truth of Allah's final
message to
mankind founded in 1991
irf today offers some of the best
services and facilities in the world for
presenting an understanding of Islam in
an objective and scientific
way its programs are primarily focused
on correcting misconceptions and
promoting understanding of
Islam irf also imparts dawa training to
D to aptly convey The Message of
Islam irf has one of the most modern
Studios producing programs presenting
Islam which are beamed regularly on many
International TV channels in over 150
countries Dr Zakir Nik president of irf
reaching out across countries worldwide
from America to Europe to Africa to Asia
to Australia strives to clarify Islamic
viewpoints he dispels the many media
myths and anti-islamic prejudices
propagated the world over by
anti-islamic forces Dr Zakir N is a
medical doctor he's acclaimed the world
over for his spontaneous and convincing
replies to questions posed by critics
and
Skeptics during the question and answer
sessions after his
talks he is also renowned for his
verbatim quotes with references from
major religious scriptures of the
world Dr Zakir and other faculty of the
irf trained many dais in effective dawa
techniques engl lat ir's website
provides free dawa training material for
you to download and become an effective
di
yourself Dr Zakir nik's talks are
available on audio and video cassettes
CDs and DVDs the world
over irf today is creating a change in
the hearts and minds of millions of
Muslims and non-muslims worldwide
towards a proper understanding and
respect for Islam have a question or
doubt about Islam and its teachings
now you know one of the best Resource
Centers to get convincing answers from
is Islamic Research Foundation 5658
tandel Street North dri Mumbai
400009 India phone 2373
6875 fax 9122 2373 0689 email Islam at
the rof.net for more information log on
to our website ww w. f.net
[Music]
oh
in the name of God most gracious most
merciful
alhamdulillah praise be to God lord of
the
worlds respected Pastor Sai
pikal on my right
Pastor Rodin Henry PO on my extreme
right Dr Zakir Nik on my
left distinguished guests ladies and
gentlemen on behalf of the
organizers the India Gospel Mission and
the Islamic Research
Foundation I welcome all of you to this
unique event today
a discussion a dialogue a
symposium a debate whatever you may
prefer to call it on the
topic was Christ really
crucified it is being held in a spirit
of friendship towards understanding each
other's
viewpoints I Dr Muhammad NY am the
coordinator
for today's program hence I will be
neutral it is my honorous duty to ensure
a fair and proper conduct of today's
meeting therefore I would request our
speakers as well as the audience
collected here today to maintain di
dearam for a healthy debate before
before we got here today I was asked by
many
people why this
topic why these speakers
only the answer to which I could Briefly
summarize in the background to this
debate pastor rockney had come to the
Islamic Research Foundation for a
discussion with Dr
Zakir it was mutually agreed between
them that instead of a personal
discussion between them it would be more
preferable and better to have an open
public debate on a particular Topic at a
convenient
Hall such that the public too could hear
and share in the debate and be the final
judge Dr Zakir suggested the
topics is the Bible God's word or was
Jesus God but Pastor rockney considered
these topics too common and instead
suggested the topic selected for today's
debate that is was Christ really
crucified that's how the topic for the
debate and the two speakers are before
all of us
today as agreed to and decided fair by
the
speakers the format for the debate will
be
Pastor rockney will address you first
for 45 minutes on the topic was Christ
really
crucified then Dr Zakir will make his
presentation on the same topic for 45
minutes then we would have a rebuttal
session in which Pastor rockney would
comment and respond for 15 minutes to
what Dr Zakir has spoken for followed by
Dr zaker to speaking and responding for
15 minutes to what Pastor rney has
presented when 5 minutes are left to
conclude the talk as well as the
rebuttal I as the Coordinator would hand
each speaker a 5 minutes left slip an
indication slip like
this in which both the speak speakers
are kindly requested to conclude their
talk or
rebuttal lastly we would have the open
question and answer session in which the
audience May pose questions to each of
the speakers
alternately on the question mics we have
provided two here next to the stage and
two in the ladies
section only if time permits we would
allow questions on slips which may be
passed on to me and I would read out to
the
speakers I would like to now briefly
introduce the
speaker Pastor rney before his talk and
I would likewise introduce Dr Zakir
before his
talk Pastor ruknudin Henry po better
known as Pastor rooky is 43 years he's
an Arab Christian Missionary he was born
a Christian in Basra Iraq and later on
brought up in Kuwait he has
postgraduated with a masters in science
from the University of
Bombay he has had varied experience in
teaching including computer Education
and
Training teaching the Arabic language
consultancy for computerization and
development of computer software
programs in
Arabic he has been in the field of
conveying the message of Christianity
for over a
decade he is a Bible teacher and
preacher with the India Gospel
Mission he is also a renowned faith
healer may I call upon Pastor rney to
make his presentation pastor rney
[Applause]
uh just small comment uh even though my
name is rukne uh it is a variation of
rukn but very rarely people call me rukn
and uh even in my official document I'm
rni so you call me
only uh
the uh there are many things we can
discuss and many things we can talk
about but practicality doesn't permit so
we settled on one topic because uh you
know other goes on and on and then
understanding will be lost so we settled
on one
topic uh you ask me why uh I suggested
this topic I suggested three things and
uh then this was selected from it uh
reason is because this is a very Central
Topic in the Christian faith and there's
a very serious difference between the
uh Muslims and the Christians in this
point so as uh Mr Nike has Dr Nike has
suggested we're going to talk very
frankly but in a spirit of friendship
and understanding so here is just we are
uh presenting our views from our side
and left for you to choose what you like
and reject what you like we respect each
other's views and even when you say no
to my views I respect your feelings and
and I totally honor your say no so I'm
just presenting the
point
now uh a few things I'll be picking up
from the Bible but if I go on picking
from the Bible then there's no end to it
because there are maybe hundreds of
verses related to the Cross
um so some things I will just say it's
from the Bible but without really
telling you where is it maybe a few
things I will read from the Bible uh
because my purpose is here not that you
memorize which part and all that just my
purpose is that you understand the
message behind it the spirit behind the
uh message of the
Cross uh why is the cross central in the
Christian faith what is the reason the
cross is so important first of all let
me comment on the cross itself
physically the
cross uh what you many people understand
I'm not saying all many people
understand the cross is the following I
go to zavi Bazar search for a not very
expensive Jeweler and have a nice shiny
little bit gold cross and hang it around
my neck and that is very suitable to
Fashion uh some will buy gold 17 some 18
some gold 21 good nice attractive
looking
cross going with fashion matching my
dress colors and all Etc that is what
many people understand of the cross even
many Christians that is the end of the
understanding of the Cross and that was
my understanding many years ago I am
born and brought up in a traditional
Christian faith I am a believer
Christian only 16 years ago I came to
India not a Believer I came to India as
a plain traditional
Christian uh but I became a Believer
here through Indians true Indians you
know so um I I received the faith in
Christ Here and Now
why the cross is so Central now the
Bible does not
refer the cross as something
attractive something uh Pleasant to
decoration in fact there is a picture
completely opposite in the
Bible the portion of the Bible in the
old part of the Bible that is the books
of the
Jews uh the first half of the Bible we
call it the Old Testament in the English
language it refers to the Cross as
something not
nice he be
surprised uh it refers to the Cross as
something
ugly it
says the cross is a place of
cursing the cross is a place where
somebody who is to be punished badly and
somebody who's cursed somebody who's
rejected by
Society the cross crossfits him and
there is a statement in the uh books of
the Jews the first half of the
Bible that says it's God's word said by
a prophets it says cursed is the man who
hangs on a
tree uh it was a reference to the tree
reference to a
cross um so uh when in the life of Jesus
the cross was not a pleasant think
desirable but it was a necessity for
something which I'll explain uh the
Bible as you are aware of uh some of you
may not be aware just quickly is made
out of two sections it is 66 collection
of 66 books uh written over a period of
approximately 4,000 years it's not one
book it's a collection of books
and uh uh the first half that is the
book of the Jews uh uh it is uh mainly
prophetic and written by prophets
various history in the life of the
history of the Jews and right from the
first book onwards there is uh sometime
almost directly but very often
indirectly reference to the
Cross now
the why there is a where does the cross
come why why why the cross I have not
yet explained it I'll try to come to the
point uh basically it's the gospel it's
a gospel the the the news of Salvation
from sin there the cross comes uh
essentially uh the Bible reveals to us
that man is a
sinner man is a sinner by Nature he
inherited that from the days of
Adam I was born and brought up and in my
nature I'm a sinner and therefore I I
Sin Sin by thoughts and by words and by
behavior and many many many things it's
the nature of man a sinner and the Bible
also
says that the person who sins he reaps
death a sentence of death uh there is a
spiritual death there's natural
Etc so there is a sentence of death on
every human being on this Earth because
of sin because sin is offensive to God
and therefore man and God cannot
Fellowship together cannot come together
because of that enemy sin between them
and now what happened
is this sin is so Grievous and so
serious and so great that whatever I do
to pay for the cost of the sin to get
rid of it it is too small not not good
enough to wipe Sin from my
life
see if I give charity to the poor it is
very nice that's a beautiful thing the
Bible recommend to do that but it is not
big enough to wipe sin for my
life as far as it a good act it is a
good act but not good enough to wipe Sin
from my life okay
now God sent Jesus a perfect man a man
without sin a man would preer prefer to
suffer rather than
sin an exception a person who sin did
not enter him he was tempted in every
way but yet he did not sin therefore the
sentence of death does not belong to him
as it belongs to all of us he deserve to
live forever
that was the quality of Jesus from the
spiritual point of view from the point
of view as man he walked as man on earth
like anybody else he had to work for his
bread and many different things like
anybody else but from the spiritual
point of view he was not worthy of death
because sin did not succeed going into
him okay so in that sense he was a
perfect man now this Jesus obeyed God to
the points of being
wrongly sentenced to the death of a
sinner okay so therefore satisfying the
justice of God that death is the price
for sin a perfect man who don't deserve
to be dead who don't deserve to taste
for death and he was willing to die on
behalf of others paying the price of of
sin therefore the cost he's paying is
worthy to wipe away
sins see the the the the sacrifices
which everybody does and trying to
remove Sin from their life is not
successful in removing sin but Jesus
because of his value of being
sinless because of his value of obing
obeying god Till the End therefore the
sacrifice he offered was acceptable to
God as a cause for sin
and there that is why the cross of Jesus
is Central in the Christian life and
that is why it is necessary for Jesus to
Die the death that God knew about it
beforehand and that's why he was um his
death was the key for those who believe
in him and those who receive that
sacrifice in their heart and accept it
they are entitled that their sin is paid
for you know it is a a cost for paying
for the sin you know that is what the
cross is in the Christian Life That's
why it is Central that's why you remove
the cross from the Christian Life you
have removed the whole Christian
faith now the dispute here is uh many
people not just Muslims some other
people also uh they they um they say say
Jesus did not die on the cross that was
uh that was uh and I'm not uh of course
doctor Zakir will know better than me in
details but my part I say Jesus did die
on the cross and I'm going to uh in the
time available as now I just give you an
idea why the cross is important Central
in our life because that death was the
key for my sins to be removed from my
life it's a free gift from God God paid
his the price himself God himself paid
the price therefore what he pays is good
and worthy enough to remove
sin not like a sacrifice I would do it
is a polluted sacrifice because a sinner
offering a sinner offering a sacrifice a
polluted sacrifice but Jesus a perfect
man offering himself though as if he was
a sinner he was willing to receive the
punishment of a sinner but he was not a
sinner it is a sentence of spiritual
death in me he said you don't die it
give it to me and I'll take it for you
and now I'm going to just go uh through
some of the historic things uh in the
scripture uh some of them are indirectly
talking about the death and the
sacrifice of Jesus some of them directly
very clearly speaking some of them
indirectly so I'll go through some of
few few things here and there as time
permits me
now uh you know the first five five
books of the Bible are written by the
prophet Moses and uh the first book is
Genesis uh that uh describe the history
of God created the earth and the first
development of human beings in the old
times in Babylon Etc now one thing is
you I'm sure some of you most of you in
school have learned at least heard about
the story of Adam and Eve how Adam and
Eve was created and he had fellowship
with God there was no barrier between
Adam and Eve and God therefore God and
Adam and Eve see each other they talk to
each other there is fellowship there is
Oneness between Adam Eve and God the
Creator why because there was no sin
between them okay that's at that's time
before sinning now later when uh the
devil who came in the uh deceiving form
of a servant and he succeeded causing
them to sin never mind what he say SED
and all that basically it's written in
the scripture some fruit they were
forbidden to eat and then they ate it
that fruit is not important what is
important is is that they did O disobey
God they did disobey God and something
God warned them that they are not
allowed to do so when they did that then
sin came to Earth and then Adam and Eve
was separated from God from that day
onwards the rift between God and man
started many people say I wish I could
see God I wish if God made know why I
can't see him why I do many people
wrongly give wrong bad attributes on God
because they see evil around them
actually evil is man has made it not God
but what happened God is righteous in
his judgment and see some of the things
that happened in the past very small
incident I'm not reading the whole thing
just small
part uh when Adam and Eve sinned against
God and then uh uh God was so so angry
with with the serpent so angry with Eve
so angry with Adam each one accordingly
received some measure of a curse in his
life now the serpent received a curse
that the serpent will be uh all the days
of her life will um crawl on the dust
and in the case of Eve uh God told her
because you have tempted your husband to
eat that which is forbidden from now on
your husband rules over you and uh
you'll be in submission to him you'll be
dependent on him and also greatly her U
birth giving um pregnancy uh there's a
great pain increased on her in the case
of Adam his main problem was that from
now on when he works in the ground the
ground doesn't give him fruit easily
he'll have to sweat and work very hard
till food
comes and uh and then their life was
limited because death entered their life
from that point onwards they are not
meant to live forever they me to but one
thing is very important
is uh related is uh is about the cross
or the indirect reference to the
Cross um see God after declaring the
various curses on Adam and Eve huh uh in
uh if you'd like to write the reference
you're free uh just I'll read it just
okay it's in the beginning of the book
of Genesis chapter 3 says therefore the
Lord God sent him out of the Garden of
Eden
Eden that is in reference to Adam and of
course and his family of Eden to till
the ground from which he was taken and
he drove the man and he placed cherubim
and so he drove out the man and he
placed cherubim at the east of the the
garden of Eden and a flaming sword which
turned every way uh to guard the way to
the Tree of Life see uh if those who
wish to refer it is Genesis 3:
2324 uh see uh simply is after God
declared the various things on them uh
and sentence of death basically on them
uh God chased them out of the garden of
Ed Eden that beautiful garden uh which
we normally refer to it as Heaven uh but
actually some beautiful place where they
used to enjoy the place God drw them out
from that garden and what did he place
at the entry point of the garden
he placed an Angelic being is called
angels have different type of categories
one of them is called the cherubim the
closest to God so Angelic beings
standing at the Gate of the garden and
he's got a flaming sword
and the sword is going right left in all
directions to make sure nobody enters
that Garden again see what is what is
the way to the Garden of Eden the the
the way to the Garden of Eden is only if
you pass through that
sword there is a sword at the G Garden
of Eden which is watching over the entry
to the Garden of
Eden and as a Christian and as I related
to other things of the the scripture
there is death price to enter the Garden
of Eden that sword has to fall on
somebody uh because God is righteous and
his Justice demands that that sword had
to fall on
somebody you see and Adam could not come
inside there's a sword guarding the
garden ofen that sword is the death
sentence on the one who dares into the
garden
and uh we see later Jesus willingly gave
his life according to the will of the
father and that sword fell on him and
therefore the G the day the today the
door to Garden of Eden the door to
Garden of Eden is
open not only to Christians to all those
who believe see I uh uh Jesus said I am
the door he said I am the door you want
to know the father you want to know the
heaven you want to know the good things
of God I am the door Jesus allowed that
sword to fall on him so that is inir
reference to the Cross I'll go a little
further
now uh Bible is Rich of indirect
references to the cross and also there
is a lot of direct reference to the
Cross just talking about cross nothing
else okay now uh another example is the
famous story of of the father of all the
faithful
Abraham now I'd like to commence
something very few know that the
Christians and the Muslims are brothers
very few knows that really brothers not
just make you not just to make you feel
happy you know really
brothers the Christians
are the spiritual descendants of
Abraham through
Isaac the Muslims are the spiritual
descendants of Abraham through Isaac
through I'm sorry ishma ishma ishma is
the brother of of Isaac really Muslims
Christians they come down from Abraham
they have brothers but they are not
natural brother they Step Brothers they
are brothers from different mothers so
when I say brother to a Muslim it's not
just to make him feel nice it's really
brother his spiritual earlier father is
Abraham prophet Abraham and my spiritual
earlier father is prophet Abraham same
Abraham okay okay so just just diversion
never mind little diversions I do here
and there I'm not a very serious teacher
uh some interesting things in between I
put uh okay now we look about Abraham um
Abraham had the famous story of being
tested concerning his son
Isaac now I know some of you are not
familiar with the Bible so I I add a few
Basics because I know not all of you
have read the Bible some of you may have
not read so I will just not put too much
details but just to get your feel of it
now Abraham God told him to come out of
UR because it's a land of sin Ur is in
Iraq it's near Basra uh I've have been
there now it's deserted there's nobody
lives there just some monuments there so
uh uh because it's a land of sin God
told him get out of get out of come I'll
take you to a land much better than this
a place better than this now Abraham did
not know what sort of a landard to him
but he obeyed God and he moved and God
did not keep his promise immediately it
took long time then for many years he
was married to Sarah and she was bad and
she couldn't bear children and for many
years he God told him I I'll give you
children so many look at the stars so
many St stars is there in the sky that
much is your children look at the sand
in the sea so much sand is there that
much children but for many years he
never had children but by faith he
believed God by faith he moved you know
by faith he moved and um after many many
many years after many years then his
wife got fed up you know and in those
days not today in those days it was not
immoral for a person to marry several
wives and even their servant women can
be a wife also in those days it was
morally perfectly all right okay now at
that time his wife told him why you
don't marry uh you our servant so you
can have at least children from her so
he did uh had a servant from Egypt her
name is Hagar so he married her and he
had
ishma but then it was time for Abraham
to have a son according to the promise
according to God's word and his own wife
Sarah became pregnant and she bore a son
Isaac imagine what is the heart of
Abraham after so many years having the
promised son you know imagine you are a
married and and and for say 20 25 years
no children God promised you a son God
promised you suppose you are a very
wealthy man who's going to take all this
money they will cheat me and they will
all take then afterwards after 20 25
years and your wife expect a baby and a
child is born imagine how is you feeling
towards that boy after so many years of
waiting for that boy that what happened
to
Abraham that was his heart attachment to
Isaac his son and then one very nice
night something very interesting
happened something very interesting
happened yes could you help me little
first Isaac test you with
Isaac 22
chapter
Genesis Isaac
uh it is in Genesis nice my pastor
nearby he'll help me to pick it up I
told you I'm not very great teacher but
the spirit of the message I'll give okay
uh even though I okay now in Genesis
chapter uh uh that is about Isaac huh
chapter 22 uh it
says now it came to pass after these
things that God tested Abraham
okay it is sounding very simple but it
was a very serious thing and said to him
Abraham I said here I am and he said
take now your son your only son Isaac
whom you love and go to the land of
morah and after him there offer and
there offer him there as a burnt
offering on one of the mountains of
which I shall tell you very terrible
thing happened to him after so many
years where and the boy become a little
teenage you know quite strong he could
carry luggage with his dad is mentioned
there so God says I want him as a
sacrifice okay now uh I'll come to the
point which I'm saying I'm not putting
all things together okay just few points
then Abraham with all the pain in his
heart Faithfully gets up early in the
morning and take all the tools necessary
to offer the sacrifice then knife the
fire Etc TR and he goes all the way to
where God told him go okay and then he
left the servant behind and took his son
and went to the Mount of morah where God
has told
him and then something very interesting
take place very very profound statement
takes place here there I'll I'll take
shortcut so uh um uh but Isaac spoke to
Abraham his father and said my father
and he said here I am my son and he said
look the fire and the wood but what is
the Lamb for a burnt
offering son say we got fire around we
got wood and me and you alone going up
the mountain where is that uh usually
they offer a goat or a lamb where is
that lamb huh now see what happens here
and and Abraham said my son God will Pro
provide for himself the lamb for a burnt
offering and the two of them went
together it's very profound statement
Abraham spoke by faith he said God will
provide for
himself an offering see he didn't say
God will provide a sacrifice he said God
will provide for himself an offering now
if you read the books of the Christians
in the New Testament that is second half
of the Bible the authors they expand on
this point and they said Abraham spoke
by faith when he spoke to Isaac when he
spoke to Isaac he was thinking that God
will raise him back from the dead when
he spoke to Isaac that's how he spoke
something like this happened but not
exactly arose him from the dead and then
they went up and then they came to the
place where God which God has told them
and Abraham the altar there and placed
the wood in order and bound Isaac his
son and laid him on the altar upon the
wood notice that his son didn't run away
he allowed his father to tie him up
although he was a big boy at that time
he could run away okay and then what
happened and Abraham stretched out his
hand and took the knife to slay his son
but the angel of the Lord called to him
from heaven and said Abraham Abraham and
he said here I am and he said do not
live lay your hand on the lad or do
anything to him for now I know that you
fear God since you have not withheld
your son your only son from me then
Abraham lifted up his eyes and looked
and there behind him was a ram caught in
the thicket by its horn so Abraham went
and took the RAM and offered it up for a
burnt offering instead of his son and
Abraham called that name of that place
the Lord will provide as it is said to
this day in the Mount of the Lord it
shall be provided see uh summary of that
thing is summary of that very D big
drama is this is Abraham went up and
then he told God will provide for
himself a lamb God is demanding a
sacrifice see I'm putting my own words
in between I'm just paraphrasing God
demanding a sacrifice there is a a a
need for a sacrifice God wants a
sacrifice but where is the where is the
Lamb the sacrifice God will provide for
himself the lamb that's what happened
and that's what happened God spared
Isaac God spared Isaac God was not even
thinking of killing Isaac the Bible
somewh else says he were just testing
Abraham God not in the business of
killing children like that God he gave
him Isaac as a gift he wouldn't just
take it like that from him okay and and
then God through miraculous act he
stopped him at the the last minute
through an angel of God in a very
critical point in his time life and he
said he gave him one some other thing to
be sacrificed not Isaac so here we
Christians we look at it this
way God spared
me God spared me I'm in the place of
Isaac anybody who believes in Jesus in
this place of Isaac God spared me from
the sentence of death of
sin there is a sentence of death of me
and God's justice demands that wages of
sin is death you see
and it is right that I should die and go
to hell okay but what happened God
provided a sacrifice for himself Christ
Jesus is the
sacrifice on the cross you look at Jesus
you believe in him you receive him in
your heart therefore God's justice is
satisfied that sacrifice instead of me
that any man dies for me is not good
enough but Christ dies for me is special
there are so many people who die for
each other there are sometime husband
died for his wife because he loves his
wife that's a very Noble act that's a
beautiful act okay but I'm talking about
saving from sin not saving from Small
Things saving from Eternal judgment From
Hell from the fire of Hell any sacrifice
will not do will not do the New
Testament the Christian part of the
Bible says
God he's talking to Believers of course
Christians and he said God delivered us
not through the blood sacrifice of blood
of goats and cows and animals and all
that I'm not hurting you feeling I'm
just telling you what it says uh but he
delivered us through the blood of his
own son Jesus Christ see that is so
Central so Central in the old New
Testament and post New Testament because
because of the sacrifice of Jesus on the
cross my sins were paid
for in the eyes of God there is a list
of sins that needs to be punished in me
but Jesus said Put it on me put on me I
I I that that list put on Jesus you see
and therefore but if somebody else die
for my sin nothing happens I will not be
safe from sin but only particular person
a perfect person is having that um uh
that privilege and to die for others he
wash away their sins see right now there
are many many things written in the Old
Testament many many things I'm not going
to read all I just going to just refer
it to youuh if you'd like to refer it
I'll help you later uh I just to know
how much time left pleas uh exactly 13
minutes left or gone left oh
R okay uh
uh the Old Testament God gave symbolism
of the Cross and uh you know the story
of uh the Jews being saved from
Egypt very famous story in the history
of the Jewish Nation they were slaves in
Egypt for several hundred years and then
God visited them and he saved them
through miraculous act and he gave them
this symbol tonight I'm going to kill
all your enemies the children of the
enemies at that time and to force them
to leave you and he made them slay a
perfect lamb a lamb without blemish not
sick not blind not limping a perfect
lamb and God told them you put the blood
of the Lamb on the doors of your house
and in the night the angel of death will
come any though that don't have that
blood their first born will be dead but
this what happened to the Jews in that
time they they obeyed and they put the
blood at the gate and the whole nation
Jews nation that night were given
permission to leave
Egypt that day I uh yeah so that was a
reference through a perfect lamb a
sacrifice of a perfect lamb not any lamb
I won't just bring any lamb for a
perfect lamb there is a Salvation from
Death that is a symbolism really it was
not the lamp it was a symbol of Christ
coming later now you go later uh one
time in the history of the Jews they
rebelled against God they did it many
times 10 major times they did it in the
Sinai and then the serpents came and
just bit them one by one and many were
poisoned through serpents it is
mentioned Fury
serpents and then God told Moses to do
something very strange very strange he
told him to make a serpent made of
bronze brass and put it on a high
stick and everybody from the Jewish
Nation looks at that serpent
he'll be healed from the poison of the
serpent now it is mentioned in the New
Testament comments on that it says see
this snake is a serpent is is a symbol
of the devil snake is not the devil
snake is just the symbol of the devil
snake is just an animal okay and now
what happened is Jesus was hung on the
cross became a serpent for us he who was
perfect more perfect than Angels but he
was willing to be like the serpent
sin on the cross you look at him you
receive him in your heart tonight your
sins are washed away tonight your sin
you're washed away you don't need some
religious ceremony tonight your sins are
washed away if you receive him you look
at Jesus who was hung on the cross that
is so Central so Central is the cross in
the Christian faith so Central and
through all the history of the Jewish
Nation God told them symbolism he gave
them symbolism to remind them of
forgiveness of sin he said you bring a
lamb that is without blemish there is no
spot on him he's not blind he's not
limping of certain age only that I
accept as your religious ritual
sacrifice God was reminding them the
future Christ the perfect blameless lamp
from the point of view of sin as man he
was just plain man like you and me he
all his godly power and author Authority
and qualities he kept asight he walked
as a plain man subject to pain and sin
sorry I'm not temptation of sin
temptation of sin so this is the central
thing now you come to the New Testament
you come to the New Testament is very
obvious about the cross the whole new
testament is based on the cross of Jesus
Paul says the Apostle Paul one of the
famous uh leaders in the New Testament
he said I preach Christ crucified I got
nothing less many people wanted Paul to
preach the Christian faith Christianity
minus cross but he refused to do that he
said I preach Christ crucified that's
the only it is foolishness in the eyes
of people who don't want to believe the
cross is foolishness from the point of
view of naturally why you your God goes
and die on the cross it sounds
foolish it is sounding foolish but
actually it is it is God's wisdom
because God's wisdom is different God
had to S satisfy his Justice God had to
be a blameless person to die for the
sins of the world today anybody who
believes in Jesus death on the cross he
was buried after 3 days he rose he
defeated death after 3 days and received
his Godly Authority again anybody who
received that act his sins are washed
away your Destin destination changed
Going to Hell going to heaven that's and
plus many other benefits that's just one
of the major benefits is then the cross
now in the New Testament is fully based
on the cross you take out the cross the
whole Bible is not worth two
pis talking Bible I mean the books of
the Jews I mean the book of the
Christians there's one chapter Isaiah 53
so clearly about this so clearly about
Jesus suffered and died so clearly so
clearly Isaiah chap 53 now lastly I got
just couple of minutes right now Lastly
lastly in the last book of the New
Testament is a prophetic book about
things in heaven one servant of God by
the name John the Apostle there are two
John's there one is John the
Apostle he saw visions of heaven and he
said things about trouble in the
euphrate war in euphrat is that's Iraq
area he predicted things what's
happening today in the Euphrates and you
can see it for yourself just read the
Times of India and you'll see all the
trouble in the Euphrates many many
things has been said but one thing very
special said he saw in
heaven the lamb that was slain see Jesus
referred to as the lamb that was slain
of course Jesus is not lamb physically
he's not a lamb he's not a sheep he's a
man okay but symbolically he was that
perfect Lamb of God where throughout
history of the Jews throughout the
history of the New Testaments God Jesus
is referred to as a lamb in heaven he's
known as the lamb that was slain uh so
if you take out the cross from the
Christian faith there is no Christian
faith that's some my list of dos and
don'ts that's all there no salvation
there's no breaking with sin there's
nothing the cross is very Central the
cross is um um is is the main thing that
God gave God died on my behalf see he
was willing to come down from heaven he
was willing to walk as man in the pains
that man taste being tempted in every
way you were tempted if you are tempted
Jesus tasted more than what you you
think okay you believe on him he breaks
that lust and that that addiction and
that bad habit and that curse in your
life Jesus breaks all that from your
life you have to just say yes to him and
tonight you go home and just pray to him
you receive salvation from sin uh I
think my time is up
okay okay good five minutes I can do
miracles in that okay praise God okay um
one thing is um uh it's for now only
okay it's my
label okay 5 minutes not bad no right uh
now uh there is one evidence of one one
category of evidence of the cross of
Jesus is the Bible that is the books of
the Jews the books of the New Testament
of the
Christians thoroughly surrounded the
cross directly and indirectly directly
and indirectly you can read it for
yourself it's available very reasonably
priced there are many Bible shops in
mumbay and if you don't know we will
tell you later okay uh uh another level
of evidence that Jesus did die and he
was sentenced to death is I'll give you
it is not from the Bible it's not from
the Bible from the enemies of Jesus
those who hated Jesus unfortunately the
Jews themselves uh historically they
rejected the message of Christ they said
this is not really Christ This is a
false Christ so finally they sentenced
him to death now if you are aware of the
the Jewish Nation they maintain current
history
book uh as major events takes place in
the Jewish Nation they record it with
their religious authorities in a book
called The tilm some of you may have
heard of it if you refer to the version
of the TM around the time of Jesus 2,000
years ago you will read that Jesus was
put to
death of course they will say wrong
things also they say he was false Christ
he gave a wrong message they say he was
a magician they said wrong things but
one thing they said they said say Jesus
was put to death because he did wrong
things uh but that is another that is
that is not religious that is outside
evidence that Jesus did die the people
who handled him they did put him to
death that's a a third third type of
evidence of the cross that is real is
the evidence of the Holy Spirit today
Christians according to the teachings of
the
Bible they pray on the sick they pray on
demons they pray on Troubles of life God
heals God testifies that these people
are teaching you correct things not in
one incident I myself was healed from a
serious spal disease there are doctors
here they know what I'm talking about
ankos spondilitis
incurable a disease that puts you in bed
you cannot walk with it a disease that
will waste your life and and 16 years
ago the leaders prayed for me uh I was
healed gradually within 7 days I was not
religious I was just believing in Jesus
I was not knowing the Bible but not read
even the Bible once at that time they
prayed for me God confirmed these people
are teaching correct things the cross is
real see God heal me and I know people I
know people Rose people from the dead
you may you may you may argue with me I
got only two maybe half a minute more I
cannot argue with you but there people
today Rose people I myself happened to
me I was walking near uh bom Jim Conner
one little girl uh uh scooter run off
over her I carried her dead she was less
than teenage now I am not a doctor I
cannot tell you about her internal
organs functioning not but as a lay man
I saw her dead she stopped breathing and
she's totally finished and we rushed her
to the hospital I was praying in Jesus
name for her and by the time we reached
the hospital she revived and she came
back to life and doctors doctors uh just
took care for observation St George
Hospital okay now that is not a
confirmed rising from the dead let's
just give you example but people
confirmed people from the dead was Rose
in the name of Jesus they defying death
today defying death they are Healing The
Sick in the name of Jesus God is giving
acts of mercy and acts of love in Jesus
name the crucified Jesus you have faith
in him God will meet your need need of
your life God will meet the need today I
don't have time I have prayed for all of
you but there's no time but some other
time maybe you could come to our meeting
at the mud Hall Club classroom on 9:00
next Sunday par Naka we could pray for
all of you my pastor will pray for you
some people in the church will pray for
you we are not great people we are not
great healers as a brother as uh huh we
are just ordinary people I'm just a
tution giver person I go around houses
and giving tutions I'm not a great
fellow even my pastor he is managing his
living somehow and his wife is working
in some Hospital like that man we are
not some he great healers we just speak
things happen but in Jesus name we hands
most of the times people receive
healings according to the faith of
course God confirming that the message
of the Cross is true there are many
different levels of proof of the Cross
thank
you thank you Pastor rney for your
presentation now we
have the second speaker for the
day Dr Zakir